we're looking for people who have star
quality so in the field there are people
who are essentially the best with people
that everybody recognizes potential
leaders in the field but we also pay
attention to people who will benefit the
most on the program Stanford ignite is
intrapreneurship and Innovation Program
it's been running on campus at Stanford
since 2006 and now we are taking it all
over the world by using highly immersive
video conference technology we're able
to bring Stanford to our international
locations our students in Bangalore in
Paris in Santiago and other locations
around the world feel as if they are in
the same room with our world-class
Stanford faculty everything from
financing and funding through
communication skills presentation skills
gives us these frameworks that help us
with design thinking making a business
model much more robust just the
practical element of trying to take an
idea and nurturing it along and really
flushing it out and building a real
pitch around it with a team that's the
most valuable thing this is kind of like
your fusion of learning and applying was
to be phenomenon very very new
experience the professor that teaches
Stanford ignite our most experienced
professors the students are really
exposed to to some of the greatest minds
of our time sharing with them what
they've learned about entrepreneurship
and innovation at Stanford and how
elsewhere in the wall and they were able
to accommodate all that questions and
give really personal attention to every
student the classroom is filled with
diverse personalities students in
engineering the life sciences education
other fields who have ideas from those
fields that they want to advance either
through startups or through the growth
of existing companies Stanford ignite is
not only about individuals it's about
creating community it is a core of a
global Stanford innovators Network this
this program has been very
transformative for me I already started
applying what I learned right away when
you give them those business skills when
you give them those tools it not only
opens up a new world for them but you
know with a huge talent they can
actually go out and create an impact the
Ignite program give us this desire to go
there and change the world